work those blue arms she says to the
alien with long sleeves on
you should be helping me construct the
earth drill really someone should help
corvo i've been watching him try to
attach this stationary panel to a very
mobile wheel since the show
started how does a spaceship this big
falling at the rate it must have been
falling crash into the
top of a house and not only do this
amount of minimal damage but
stay on the house
what a dumb place to teleport yourself
this guy has an alien lab
or a house with a first aid kit why the
yard
he's wearing a dick wolf t-shirt and i
think this show may be my soul mate
guess i have a new shirt at the top of
my fbi's most wanted list
planet shlorp was a perfect utopia until
the asteroid hit
using expositional narration for your
opening title sequence
even if it is freaking hilarious don't
look at them if you don't want people to
look at your toe sprouts then grab an
afghan and cover those nubs
setting a full open bag of potato chips
on your lap sideways
these chips are defying gravity high
schoolers deciding to hang out in front
of the high school establishing shot
even though classes are certainly
already underway because the sun is
already out cliche
ah sudden naruto headband i seen that
show six months ago and i still have
nightmares about precocious children
that can't speak below 100 decibels
i can't help it reflexive sin i slowed
this down to confirm that that is a
giant spit ball that takes out yumilac
and my question is how did you prepare a
head-sized spitball and launch it with
that force so quickly
i don't think we should have to go to
school with aliens who are probably
gonna zap us with their ray gun
don't be raised i believe you mean
that's racist
come on down to the gretchen darth maul
for the annual mega sale
look i love exclamation points as much
as the next guy i can even accept up to
five of them after any sentence you want
to emphasize
but the line has to be drawn somewhere
and i'm drawing it at pre-word
points this is echo name abuse and it
shall not stand
i need to learn everything about fun
bucket does he have a penis does he
reproduce and just like that corvo was
added to the tv since writing team no
questions asked
no terraforming the gym or making pod
people or any of that outer limits
[ __ ]
taking the outer limits name in vain
also using two different colored tacks
when there's another red one sitting
right there
you could then use that blue one on the
other sheet and have two perfectly good
matches you tack jumbling chaos monster
giving up on a plant getting super
precious about the e at the end of your
name
also inside jokes like that e joke you
just did
danae what did you do with fun bucket
what did you do with the pupa
this tiny thing is apparently a very
important part of your alien race's plan
to repopulate itself
and you leave it home alone fun bucket
isn't real you
idiots yes he is we watch him on tv sure
you're advanced enough to understand the
fluent nuances of the english language
and the day-to-day life of earth but you
don't know how to distinguish between
fiction and reality on television
what are you a cable news network tv
lied to us
this entire episode's a plot would be
out of this world at tv sins
you guys aren't gonna try to [ __ ] me are
you no i mean you were awfully
interested in their genitalia earlier so
this is a valid question
and sin hey check out who's real i'm
sure he's already seen him considering
they apparently bought stuff from the
exact same stores
our bodies only make googlers during
extreme destruction he knows this
he's an alien too you're expositioning
corvo and it's even more disgusting than
your gooblering
there is a chance that we will overheat
and die if corvo's concerned about
overheating perhaps traveling to the
earth's core would have been a concern
they tried to copy our outfits no they
did copy your outfits
your exact outfits i don't think this
show understands how much stalking and
groundwork it takes to take over
someone's exact appearance like this
so i hear put your scene in me oddly
specific requests but
okay extreme and gratuitous violence in
a justin royland show because blood is
hilarious cliche
and somehow no equipment will be harmed
in this digestive acid bath
johnson was last seen monday her parents
are pleading for any information that
leads to her safe return
is there any show or movie that doesn't
do this it's death
taxes and news position just adjust the
old saying now and be done with it
wait we can't park here there's street
cleaning tomorrow
so maybe park in the driveway despite
having been examined by countless
scientists over hundreds of years the
human brain is still a mystery says the
alien who only seconds ago said
what's a brain everyone is mean to them
speaking with your skull open
we weren't gonna kill her we were just
reprogramming her a little says the
alien who only seconds ago had this
conversation
we could dissolve i'll get the acid
apparently before they crash to earth
they spent a few semesters at the
stormtrooper school of aiming at things
people who own helicopters perhaps the
most unbelievable part of this show is
this fresh market style school cafeteria
also this cafeteria setup is a disaster
first you've got your fruit all mixed in
a bowl up here including bananas which
we've
already talked about but then you've
also got bananas down here neither of
which are under the fruit sign
and i don't see any chips under the chip
sign either listen buddy you don't
promise me chips and then not deliver
chips
feel my wrath i used to be small but now
i'm big i am peeing my pants uh things a
penis might say
good night mr janitor you know what
would be awesome if they set up this
shrunken janitor like it was just a joke
then used an entire episode later that
took place in this ecosystem to develop
a full culture and hierarchy that
allowed them to not only do a one-off
episode completely in this sub-universe
but also include it later in the show's
larger plot lines that would be amazing
too bad that will never happen
you told me i wasn't a clone you're not
a clone
and who is that hey it's in week that
means we are releasing
two videos here on youtube and three
extras for our sin club members
head to patreon.com cinemasons to watch
this week's extra sins videos
and while you're there click around to
discover over 70 other exclusive videos
and podcasts just for members
what you want more fine we also have
merch discount codes and access to our
discord
more god damn well you can get two
months free when you sign up for the
annual plan but that
is it join the sim club now at
patreon.com
cinemasense
[Music]
morty let's see what else is on huh okay
and now we're back to how did i get here
the only show
that makes you ask yourself how did i
get here
why does that one look new just a flesh
wound who wants to go
i'll camping what have we done great now
i have
guilt you're all ready for biz
[Music]
i'm watching you you creepy little
[ __ ] aliens i'm
watching you wazowski always watching